-The Trump administration is
dealing with crises both natural
and of its own making,
from hurricanes
to a series of scandals
involving cabinet members.
So naturally, President Trump
spent the weekend attacking
athletes for peacefully
protesting police brutality.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tensions with North Korea
over its nuclear program
are escalating,
and there's currently
an urgent humanitarian crisis
in Puerto Rico
where more than 3 million
American citizens
are currently without power
after Hurricane Maria.
So President Trump decided
what our nation needed most
this past weekend was one more
[bleep] thing
for us to deal with.
-President Donald Trump says
athletes who take a knee
during the National Anthem
should be fired.
-It all started on Friday when
President Trump went on a tear
during a rally in Alabama.
Here's a reminder of what
he said, and I should warn you,
some, especially young ones
in the room,
are going to find this
language offensive.
-Wouldn't you love to see one
of these NFL owners,
when somebody disrespects
our flag,
to say, "Get that son of a bitch
off the field right now.
Out. He's fired"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
"He's fired!"
-Let's just take a step back and
consider how embarrassing it is
that news anchors now
have to introduce comments
from the President by warning
little children
to leave the room.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Donald Trump -- Donald Trump is
our first NC-17 President.
And it's not even a good
NC-17 movie.
Trump is basically
the "Showgirls" of Presidents.
[ Laughter ]
Trump's Presidential Library
is gonna be in the back
of the video store
where they keep all the pornos.
[ Laughter ]
You're gonna have to enter
through a beaded curtain.
You guys got "The State
of the Union" back here?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's unhinged rant only got
worse from there
when he bizarrely suggested that
NFL ratings were down
because people would rather
watch him.
-The NFL ratings are down
massively.
Now the number one reason
happens to be
that they like watching
what's happening on...
You know? With yours truly.
-That's right.
In Donald Trump's mind,
people are turning off
NFL games,
gathering their friends,
and ordering pizza
to watch an out of shape
blowhard shuffle around
like he got separated
from a tour group.
[ Laughter ]
But...
[ Cheers and applause ]
But when you think about it,
Trump is better than the NFL
because with Trump,
you get all of the concussions
with none of the hitting.
[ Laughter ]
Trump talks like he just got
his bell rung. Someone should
always be checking his eyes
with a pen flashlight. How many
fingers am I holding up?
[ Imitates Trump ]
"3 million illegal voters."
[ Normal voice ]
This guy's done for the day.
[ Applause ]
Trump then went on to claim
that the other reason ratings
are down is that viewers
are turning off games
when they see players kneel
during the Anthem.
-But you know what's hurting
the game more than that?
When people like yourselves
turn on television,
and you see those people
taking the knee
when they're playing
our great National Anthem.
[ Audience booing ]
-Sorry, what?
[ Laughter ]
What was that hand motion?
Can we see that again?
[ Booing ]
[ Laughter ]
Does he turn his TV off
by stabbing it?
[ Laughter ]
Or is that just him
poking his butler
to make him change it?
[ Imitating Trump ]
I don't like this anymore.
Turn it off, Jeeves!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Aristocratic voice ]
Very well, sir, very well.
[ Applause ]
Trump then doubled down
on his claim about the ratings
and attendance,
tweeting over the weekend...
And by asking fans
to boycott the league,
Trump was attacking
the pocketbook of many who would
use their pocketbooks
to help Trump.
-Mr. Trump's criticism
led to sideline demonstrations
yesterday
at stadiums across the country.
-During the Anthem, players
joined arms, sat or knelt.
Even Redskins owner, Dan Snyder,
a Trump supporter, joined in.
Shahid Khan, the league's
only Muslim owner,
and a Trump supporter,
locked arms with his team,
the Jacksonville Jaguars.
-New England Patriots owner
Bob Kraft,
who gave Mr. Trump
a Super Bowl ring
and contributed to his campaign,
says he was deeply disappointed
by the President's comments.
-He gave Trump
a Super Bowl ring,
and now Trump is attacking
the NFL.
This is a reminder that
supporting Trump
is a lot like robbing a bank --
just when you think
you got away with it,
the dye pack explodes.
[ Explosion ]
-[ Yelling ]
[ Applause ]
-By now, it should be clear to
everyone who Donald Trump is
and what he represents.
When black athletes peacefully
protest racism
and police brutality,
Trump has no trouble
summoning his outrage,
but when white supremacists
march with Nazi flags,
Confederate flags
through the streets
of an American city,
he equivocates
and then defends them.
But Trump wasn't content
to feud with just one
massively popular sports league
this weekend.
He decided to tangle
with the NBA as well
after seeing a
"Fox & Friends" segment
on Steph Curry's decision
not to go to the White House
with the Golden State Warriors.
Trump saw that and tweeted...
But this prompted a response
from Lebron James himself,
who tweeted at Trump...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is there anything...
Is there anything better than
calling Donald Trump a bum?
"Bum" is such a great old-timey
sports insult.
He talks about the President
the way guys in fedoras
used to talk about a 42-year-old
overweight boxer.
[ Deep voice ] "He's a bum."
[ Laughter ]
There were
so many memorable responses
to the President's comments
this weekend,
but if you were angry
and frustrated,
you might have found some
catharsis in this tweet
from Buffalo Bills running back
Lesean McCoy, who wrote...
I have to say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The most devastating part of
that is the ellipsis.
You can almost see McCoy
tenting his fingertips
and going, "mm, how shall I put
this? Ah! I know, accurately."
[ Laughter ]
Because you think he's gearing
up for a longer rant,
and then he just calls
the President an ass[bleep].
[ Laughter ]
That's like sending a friend
a text that says "I have
something very important
I need to tell you," and then
typing for 10 minutes
so all they see are dots
and then following up
with "You suck."
[ Laughter ]
Trump, of course, only dug in
after that,
obsessively tweeting over
the weekend about sports,
despite tweeting not once about
the crisis in Puerto Rico.
On Saturday, he wrote...
Okay, first of all,
it's not a privilege.
The players are the sport,
and without them,
there is no league.
There's a reason DIRECTV
has a Red Zone Channel
and not an Owners Box Channel.
[ Laughter ]
And second, it wasn't just
athletes protesting
police brutality who stood up
against Trump this weekend.
He also heard harsh rebukes
from football analysts
who aren't exactly known
as radicals.
-What would you say to the
President about all this stuff?
-I would say he should
apologize.
Um, they're not SOBs.
They're smart, thoughtful guys.
-When I heard the comments,
I was so disappointed because
I believe the comments are
completely contradictory
to what the flag represents.
-There was even this comment
from Trump supporter Rex Ryan.
-I supported Donald Trump.
You know, I sat back,
and when he asked me to
introduce him
at a rally, you know,
in Buffalo, I did that.
But I'm reading these comments,
and it's appalling to me.
-Oh, so you supported Trump,
and then he let you down?
Better cover your eyes.
[ Explosion ]
-[ Yells ]
-It will go off.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look, these athletes aren't just
speaking for themselves.
They're using their platform
to call attention
to racial injustice
and speak out for others,
and here now to use her platform
to do the same, "Late Night"
writer, Amber Ruffin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yay!
Thanks, Seth!
Fool!
You cannot win a Twitter war
against black people!
What is wrong with you?!
I woke up on Saturday and heard,
"Trump is attacking
black people,"
and I was like, he is?!
And then they were, like,
"verbally."
And I was like, "Oh, thank God."
[ Laughter ]
Trump said when people
kneel for the National Anthem,
they should "kick that son
of a bitch off the field."
You know someone is racist
when they don't even want
black people in their field.
[ Laughter ]
And for the record, I would take
a knee in a second,
unless a black lady was singing
the National Anthem,
because that is too dang long
to be on one knee.
[ Laughter ]
Then Donald Trump disinvited
Steph Curry to the White House
after he said he wasn't going.
That's like me saying,
"Taye Diggs, you can never come
over to my house."
He wasn't coming over
in the first place!
[ Laughter ]
Taye, this was just a joke
for a television show.
Um, Please come to my home
anytime you like.
If my husband answers the door,
don't worry.
He knows of our arrangement.
I get Taye Diggs, and he gets
an hour of silence.
[ Laughter ]
People are on Twitter talking
about how the players are
"ungrateful."
There is not enough time to
unpack why that is a gross thing
to say to a black person.
Also, how are black people
ungrateful when you called
the White House a dump?!
Don't nobody want to eat
at your dump with you!
[ Laughter ]
Also...
[ Cheers and applause ]
No athlete wants to have dinner
with you
because no one wants to eat
whatever it is you eat!
Because maybe it's the food
you eat
that makes you look like that!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys, this is about
racial inequality.
Look, if you have a problem
with black people
loudly protesting
and silently protesting,
then what you have a problem
with is black people.
What is your ideal form
of black protest?
Write down our complaints,
put 'em in a bottle,
and throw 'em
in the [bleep] ocean?
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Would you like it if our
complaints were mournfully sung
in an old Negro Spiritual?
[ Deep voice ]
♪ My President's ♪
♪ A white supremacist ♪
♪ If he keeps on a-tweeting,
I'm-a gonna be pissed ♪
[ Normal voice ] Oh, my God!
That does make me feel better!
Look, let me be clear about what
is happening here.
Trump is trying to make sure
to let black people know
that if we don't fall in line,
we will be punished.
Well, guess what?
If slavery didn't break us,
this idiot certainly can't,
you raggedy fool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Back to you, Seth.
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This weekend was in many ways
the perfect distillation
of Trump's Presidency,
feeding his base racial
and cultural resentments
in order to keep them
on his side
as his team
of corrupt authoritarians
tries to swindle
hard-working Americans
out of their health care,
or you know what?
To quote Lesean McCoy,
our President is an ass[bleep].
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]